Shoppers at this Nordstrom department store in Minneapolis...
...have some new choices with the addition of headscarves...
...from the local Somali-American design firm Henna & Hijabs.
CEO Hilal Ibrahim says Muslim women are underrepresented in US retail.
So, this partnership is really special.
We work together to create pieces in this collection...
...that will be sold in stores across the country and in Canada...
...and my hope is that young Muslim women and girls will be able to walk into Nordstrom stores...
...and now purchase their full outfit including their hijab as well.
Ibrahim started selling hijabs at a local hospital gift shop...
...when she saw some patients had to cover their heads with blankets.
Partnering with her firm on this line of silk, cotton and chiffon hijabs...
...is just the opportunity Nordstrom was looking for...
...says the company's Senior Director of Diversity, Mohammed Omar.
The work here with Henna & Hijab and Hilal Ibrahim...
...really exemplifies the work that we've been going after for some time...
...and helping to bring product lines to different segments of the market...
...that have been untouched before.
Ibrahim say partnering with Nordstrom helps make hijab...
...a more visible part of American culture.
As a Somali Muslim American woman, it showcases that it's okay.
Hijabs are normal.
It's a part of American culture, and I want to normalize that.
I want people to come into stores and see hijabs and say,...
..."That is just as American as wearing a t-shirt."
Nordstrom says Ibrahim's hijab collection is available online...
...and in 16 stores across North America.